[Music]
president biden begging democrats to
save his rear end before jetting off to
europe to see the pope
joe tell him joe telling dems behind
closed doors to either pass his massive
spending plans or his presidency is
toast
he then announced that his party has
reached the framework on a 1.75
trillion dollar deal that he says will
transform america
any single element of this framework
would fundamentally view but would be
viewed as a fundamental change in
america taken together
they're truly consequential when paired
with the bipartisan infrastructure bill
will truly transform this nation as i
said before these plans are fiscally
responsible
they are fully paid for
they don't add a single penny to the
deficit i want everyone to be able to if
they want to be a millionaire or a
billionaire to be able to seek their
goal
but all i'm asking is
pay your fair share
okay
but so far radical democrats say almost
two trillion dollars doesn't go far
enough and are threatening to blow up
biden's big plans
so you're not on board with this
framework as it's now drafted i want to
see your language i want to see it
improved you are a no if nancy pelosi
were to bring up this infrastructure
vote in the next day or so next couple
of days if it's if it's by itself if
it's a stand alone absolutely i'm 100 to
know there is no getting me to a yes
progressives have also been clamoring to
see text of the bill
pelosi just dropped the 2400 pages worth
so bust out your reading glasses jesse
old man
as as for when a vote actually happens
nancy pelosi is being crystal clear
are you holding an infrastructure vote
today have you made that decision
we thought i had to say
so are you holding an infrastructure
vote today are you holding an
infrastructure
ah a true leader so jesse there is a
democrat victory in here they have made
it so americans see 1.75 as a small
number because they began with yeah 3
trillion which means
their strategy actually worked and were
screwed that's weird well we're screwed
i don't think the strategy worked i
think it was a total mess and i hope i'm
wrong but i do think they're going to
get something passed within the next
five days so they give joe a win
overseas so he can beat his chest to the
world and they got to get something done
under the wire before that election on
tuesday too so the media is now going to
write this story this is the comeback
kid and that's just going to be an
inside the beltway story though because
for the rest of the american people this
two-headed monster of a bill is not
going to affect them in a positive way
especially in the short term does
nothing for the border or inflation does
nothing for the supply chain and does
not create jobs if anything the
democrats are going to own inflation
when they're spending trillions on top
of what we already have right now they
already own the border crisis and
they're slipping in this bill i did read
some of it greg
amnesty for 10 million illegal
immigrants they are going to own high
gas prices because they slipped in a
little green new deal here and they're
going to own the weak recovery because
they're going to raise taxes higher than
it's ever been done before
in a couple years you may have
government-run day care in a couple once
they get that off the ground but in the
near term private day care is going to
skyrocket because they're going to have
to compete with this new program and
then what maybe in one year they're
going to have a few electric car
charging stations great only two percent
of us own an electric vehicle so that's
not really that great
some of the spending is good you know
you want wi-fi and nice railroads and
less traffic but a lot of this is just
doubling down on the boondoggle of
bankrupt programs like medicaid and
medicare which aren't really doing that
well right now so this country's gonna
sit around what for the next couple days
and watch a bunch of untalented
politicians bad at arithmetic try to
raise taxes so they can square the
numbers to see if they can pay for stuff
that no one wants or needs that's
basically what we're watching right now
kudos to your assistant for reading that
stuff and then boiling it down to a
paper for you yes but here's the thing
shannon he may know some of the facts
but at 2 400 pages we never know we keep
repeating the same mistake that's the
worst part about this we know that most
of this is crap in there but no one
reads it because it's impossible this
that's the big lie is that we're
actually know what's going on well and
the thing is i know that you think maybe
it's a foregone conclusion they get
something done we literally just got an
email from jason donner one of our very
intrepid capitol hill producers who just
talked to manchin who said we're working
together in good faith moving forward
we're hearing the same thing from
senator cinema you've got a lot of folks
over in the house uh it looks like the
speaker's not ready to pull the trigger
on this infrastructure vote because they
don't seem like they're actually
convinced and all on board either so i
think what the president came out and
said today is like we've made progress
but i don't think we've seen a press
release from anyone saying we have a
deal right so i think in dc there's
still a lot of steps to go here um you
got to think too they're trying to sneak
in as you said the stuff about
immigration the parliamentarian has
ruled against them on this and they've
acknowledged that senator dick durbin
one of the top democrats said we know
but we're going to try again so they
know that they're kind of throwing
everything at the wall so they can say
they've got to win but big things that
people expected and wanted in like
democrats have run for years on lowering
prescription drug prices it looks like
now that's not going to be a part of the
bill a lot of things that people said we
got to have it or we're not going to do
it that's in there and you know we
played in the opening the president did
his interesting whisper thing where he
says pay your fair share three times pay
fair share pay fair share well according
to the irs a non-partisan group the top
five percent of income earners pay 60
of income taxes so that's up to the
american people where they think that's
enough yeah that's all they rely on is
that phrase pay your fair share it's not
going to work anymore because people
have the internet they know what people
are paying geraldo he went to visit the
pope
what do you think of the pope you know
him don't you hang out
you got dinner with him
i like the pope i'm half catholic so i
could hang out with no such thing half a
day
no i am i am half catholic and half
jewish but i feel fully catholic and
fully jewish so if you can't get your
mind around that then you don't
understand your colleague um
you know what disappoints me the most
here is how the progressives and the
squad have been revealed as as uh you
know par uh poly part petty politicians
who would not allow an infrastructure
bill to go forward where they would be
the you know the bridges repaired and
the streets and the uh you know the and
the wi-fi i mean they could have done
so graciously
yes we want this big bill or the other
bill to remake society and all the rest
and be very generous to the least
amongst us but let's uh let's do this
for everybody where everybody benefits a
highway that's smooth without
holes in it that benefits the rich and
the poor alike i i and the fact that
they were against it and they used their
power to screw pelosi and force her into
this uh un unwieldy uh bill i think is
is really disappointing to me because i
have been a huge fan of their uh
of their energy of their new insights uh
you know and their idealism but they are
revealed to be rather than idealistic
they're revealed to be
politicians ruthless politicians of a
different sort i can't believe
that they are ruthless politicians oh my
god anyway katie i go to you last
because i want you to help me i'm an lwh
i'm a libertarian without hope okay i i
feel that we've gone to this place where
you have people are gonna be relieved to
have a two trillion dollar bill that's
2500 pages
and that means that means essentially
anybody who believes in small government
it's over it's dead well i'm going to
give you some hope i know you'll reject
it because you're a libertarian without
hope but i will give you some of it if
you look at the polling on uh this
reconciliation package in every state
that's run by you know democrats but
also republicans purple states west
virginia for example arizona people are
against this kind of spending and so
even if they pass it and get it shoved
down their throats they're going to look
at it next year maybe in 2024 and say
we watched what you did we didn't want
it and you voted for it anyway depending
on how these votes go down now
someone's gonna have to blink here it's
either gonna have to be senator cinema
and senate mansion or these
socialists i will not call them
progressive socialists in the house who
are holding this up because a deal was
made this summer on infrastructure
between republicans and democrats at the
white house the president promised they
would not go together to be voted on
they're changing that now it was
interesting to watch nancy pelosi come
out today kind of exacerbated saying i'm
releasing the text so you can complain
about it which is pretty funny uh so
we'll see what they can do but joe
biden's on the verge of being a lame
duck president he doesn't have much time
to get anything done and at this point
he can't get infrastructure done and he
can't get the reconciliation
reconciliation package done and
therefore he has nothing to show the
first year in his presidency which does
not give him a lot of strength and
negotiating power moving forward you
know he should talk to hunter the
smartest man he's ever met as far as
where do you get that 10 million
illegal aliens getting amnesty did you
make that up i read it in the text you
did not yeah not this text but the
previous in the framework the prefix in
the framework it's a pretext it's in the
framework back dating to 1979 for some
of the
all right what do you mean by well
they're back getting some of the status
for people who came here earlier
you're talking about dreamers the word
is amazing
i mean hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else